welcome to this video bharat on from
finland yo we got a queen's gambit and
Slav let's see let's do the main line
and see what is coming up with the
chabanenko okay you're here Bishop f5 is
the modern move okay well this is
possible as well let's see Bishop d3
then you can probably place you fire
jello let's just plan on a moose ok this
one now this I didn't expect hmm I go
see 5 or not and the bishop on d3 is not
really that great for this c5 c5 kind of
structure I'm going to try to play here
four nights you want to be three
okay to see get to see four maybe okay
sorry I definitely don't want to play
sorry be three then my night is not know
where it wants to go and see three is
terribly weeks out not not a good idea k
well as this is okay I wonder i want
that I wonder see mia e five but still
rook see one should be okay i was
thinkin thinkin I'm slightly better snow
but maybe maybe that's not the case
let's put this here that I had the idea
to play F for him as well just just
blocking everything this is this invites
my knight to c6 and he says go ahead
okay I don't really see where he's going
with the Queen there that looks strange
I mean he has to do that probably but
but still 994 is coming maybe
now this that's not bad for black 96 I
should have really considered a bit a
bit more a bit more thoroughly it's
really not there's really nothing radium
I have no tactic or anything like 95 for
bishop tix before we know not really on
and 94 is a very annoying move when it
when it hits
it's the kind of thing you just play
like 96 nice but you should really think
about what is your next move because now
I don't have a next move
check
yeah i know this is this amounts to very
little but he can't a Quincy five you
okay I've not be three it's not not
terrible habit 96 was really a
completely completely lemon which is
just nothing absolutely nothing
at least a lot in trouble it's probably
f3 wait f 34 Quincy five maybe a slight
something yeah maybe maybe I can
probably play Queen the age okay taking
95 is good for white but you can play
you can play Queen the end oh I thought
this would be good for me but maybe not
the ship's is six I scott d 4 i'm sorry
he's got d4 of course time morning and i
have to go back no way takes that a 495
ok kind of i'm overlooking little things
here
ki just protected everything this is a
this is a kind of a self pin right I can
also go here just attack you five
40 seconds we should be five in 94
smooth I've wanted to play with years
bishop is ok now I can do it whether
that's very nice now very nice and game
and relatively simple to play right
ahead to hit the check of course already
check
okay let's think about it for a moment
what's the best way to do that
my idea is to give up the pawn and then
promote just not completely sure what
the best way to do it what's the best
way to do it maybe this JK have to have
to change for it at some point
black resigns oh wow yeah that didn't
really didn't really look like a win for
a very long time around here rotya
nothing much is happening I definitely
am NOT better or anything achieve he
gave me some possibilities here thought
you should just go back or is there a
problem with that okay I can take a five
I didn't see that okay take stakes and
this whoo-chow might be three hours I
was a bit shocked for one moment because
of this but it's really not knocked up
grade and here i would say i'm better
earlier I'm just winning the poem yeah
this this was getting getting very nice
the pure bishop endgame is a it's a
pretty simple win I'm not sure I'm
probably didn't play it in the best
possible way but there was a song check
there was on one moment where I could
hear no I couldn't play we should be
fired yeah yeah but check round here
this is easier I can I can invade us
much easier but okay the win is a win
thanks for watching